foreign
so a few days ago a mother in New Jersey
called Angela Redding found out that her
child's Elementary School was
advertising something called
pansexuality and she thought this seems
a little much for an elementary school
so she complained about it on Facebook
what happened next didn't used to happen
in this country and never should and we
only know about it because of a substant
called chaos in control which broke the
story and as we read it we thought this
can't be real but it is so in response
to Angela Redding's post out of the blue
an army officer at Joint Base mdl it's a
nearby military base called Angela
Redding an extremist on Facebook that
officer is called Lieutenant Colonel
Christopher Schilling Schilling then
wrote on Facebook that quote The Joint
Base leadership have had the security
forces working with multiple state and
local law enforcement agencies to
monitor this situation
what
so the military responded to a mom in an
elementary school complaining about the
sexualization of her own child that's a
warranted a military response under Joe
Biden apparently it did then shortly
after the chief of the North Hanover
Police Department Robert Duff pressured
Redding to delete her Facebook post
let that sink in the police and the
military got involved because a mom
wrote something on Facebook they didn't
like
today Joint Base mdl confirmed to this
show that they quote notified law
enforcement about the social media
exchange which is common information
sharing practice among law enforcement
agencies
except wait a second a military base is
not a quote law enforcement agency the
purpose of the military is defend us
from foreign enemies not to police our
Facebook posts
this is mind-boggling and we pray
someone does something about it Angela
Redding is the mother who wrote that
Facebook post of the military shutdown
she joins us tonight Angela thank you so
much for being brave enough to come on
were you a little surprised that the U.S
military weighed in on your Facebook
post
um I was more than surprised I was
scared I actually pulled my kids from
school the day I found out it was it was
mind-boggling and I was worried for them
when the U.S military comes after you
for simply raising concern about a
public poster that is widely available
for all to see it it's just it's it's
mind-boggling as you said and just to be
clear you weren't threatening War you
didn't threaten to use nuclear weapons
against the school correct no actually
my post was really moderate it
essentially said that I didn't think my
seven-year-old was age appropriate to be
exposed to words such as polysexual and
pansexual I said that all people are
deserving deserving of love and respect
that my post was very explicit about
that and still it prompt that this
response and and it is really scary that
in this country we can't have a right to
speak and raise concerns that about our
public education system
you live in an area with a lot of
military families I know I think your
children's school has a lot of military
families in it I mean you and I doubt
was your respect the military because
almost all Americans do
um did you know that they're reading
your Facebook posts I did not and I
actually want to be really explicit I
believe that our military personnel
deserves the utmost love admiration of
respect I'm a I'm a daughter of a
veteran I live in a community with the
military and these are phenomenal
families our school district is
phenomenal the teachers in our school
district are phenomenal I think this is
a rogue actor a bad faith actor and I
don't think that we need to implicate
the entire population but I I did not
think that the military was uh
monitoring mom's Facebook post no I did
not no and you would hope that
Lieutenant Colonel Schilling would be
removed from his command tonight
um and we'll be seeing uh if he is what
was the role of the police chief can you
just tell us that quickly yeah so I
actually
um got a call from the admin of the
Facebook group again this is kind of
ridiculous we're talking about this this
was a it's a parents group that I posted
on I got a call from the admin with
faith groups groups and saying that the
police chief contacted her to say that
my post should be should come down and
she said what do you think I said well I
don't want Homeland Security coming
after me take the post down like I I
don't want to be dealing with this so I
agreed that the post could come down I
then contacted the police chief directly
and reminded him of the First Amendment
and that we shouldn't be utilizing
government resources and our positions
to pressure individuals to take down
Facebook posts and I also you know
shared with him the post that he had
already seen there was nothing wrong it
didn't violate any law it didn't violate
any Facebook rule whatsoever so that's
how that all happened and you know we're
here today I hope Chief Huff is relieved
of his post immediately too because
that's just that's I've never heard
anything like this and I hope I never
hear it again but I appreciate your
telling us about it Angela Redding thank
you so much thank you subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight